[Music]
[Applause]
hello welcome to this Hill sale college
online course on the book of Genesis a
very great thing
my name is Larry iron I work here at the
college I'm going to introduce this
course I'm gonna start by thanking you
we're very proud of these online courses
I think this is the 24th of them and
we're proud of that number of you who
watch them and we're proud of your
reaction to them and apart from the
nature of the students at Hillsdale
College it's one of the most helpful
things we know so thank you very much
wherever we can be helpful to you that's
what we're here for we've decided that
we love to learn and we love to teach
and if somebody wants to join us we
invite them I'm also going to do three
things by way of introduction to the
course I'm going to say why and how we
teach the book of Genesis at Hillsdale
College and I'm going to say a few
things about the book of Genesis which
professor Justin Jackson a very great
teacher is going to speak about much
more fully and I'm going to introduce
Justin Jackson one of my favorite people
so the reason why we do everything here
comes from a mission that was written
for the college by people I think were
heroic people many of them friends of
Abraham Lincoln some of them who served
in the cause and helped to build the
cause that he served and and led and
they wrote in 1844 and articles of
association and articles of association
that's a beautiful document
it's the document I read that persuaded
me to come here and it establishes four
things is the purposes of the college
they're pillars of the college you might
say one of them is sound learning and
that means high learning that means the
study of ends especially the ultimate
ends toward which human life is
organized and it means the building of a
moral character that is to say the human
being in action being brave and moderate
and just and practically wise those are
the cardinal virtues and they're very
much written into the history
this place and into this articles of
association and then the third is the
teaching of the Christian faith by
precept and example and the fourth is
freedom the right of the human being to
be free in part sort of at the peak to
exercise his mind to understand the
things around him and pick his way and
of course all the other freedoms follow
underneath that and so we've always
stood for those four things for learning
for character for faith and for freedom
and those things today and the way we
understand things sort of jar
against each other for example sound
learning and higher learning they have
to do with the intellect and the
operation of the mind what have they to
do with moral action with being brave
was Socrates brave did he need to be so
so are they related and our view of that
is the human being is an integrity of
body and soul and so the excellence of
the human being the virtues of the human
being would involve both the body and
the soul and they come together and then
this other thing is even more troubling
troublesome and bigger and it is raised
by this course on Genesis and that is
why would a place devoted to learning to
the exercise of the mind to rational
understanding also be interested in
faith aren't they contradictory and that
I will address it a little bit of length
because that would be why we study
Genesis here philosophy is the love of
wisdom and wisdom is an achievement of
the intellect of what you can know by
thinking things through and so you
wouldn't in philosophy you wouldn't
build your premises on the basis of
something in which you have faith very
much not the way you do it you try to in
fact in philosophy the way we teach it
here which is well and also teach it in
some other departments to politics for
the
teaches a lot of political philosophies
as an example we kind of start with the
things in front of us and try to
understand how we know what they are
same thing one of the things in front of
us is each other ourselves what are we
and so you start with questions Socratic
philosophy begins this way it was
what are we how should we live what are
these other things we see and how do we
know what they are how do we figure it
out and there's a great account of that
in classical philosophy and classical
philosophy of course was born in a time
before the Christian phase in pagan
times 400 or so years before Christ
and their account runs like this they
say well you know when you start
thinking about how you recognize things
you're asking the question how do you
use common nouns down there there's a
glass which they put here for me in case
I get raspy and I'll hold it up so you
can see it right and if you think about
it that's one glass it's a kind there
are many kinds many many kinds and
somehow we always recognize them and if
this was the glass then something that
differed from it would not be a glass
and so it's kind of hard to say exactly
what do we see and the fact that we can
use the common noun glass is the central
upper operation according to the
classics of human reason it's the thing
we can do that the other creatures can't
do and if you think about that for a
minute it opens up a rich world for us
because the way I put the point I've
said it so many times that I'm fond of
it and everybody else is tired of it but
in my family we raise children and boxer
dogs and for the first two years we
raise them just alike they live on the
floor they eat each other's food they
act badly in their own way but then when
the kids get to be about two they start
talking and the dogs never do and
they've all heard all the same things
why do the dogs not talk why did the
children talk nobody teaches them to
talk they just hear and they pick up
something that other creatures don't
and yet when we realize that about
ourselves and look inside ourselves we
see that whatever it is about us that
makes us different that thing too is
imperfect first of all it's located in a
perishable body and second of all we
have this thing that is about us about
the way we learn and the way we think
that's the reason why students get dark
circles under their eyes at finals time
we go from one thing to the next thing
to the next thing and we have to piece
them together while we go we don't know
everything at once we can't really see
anything except what we can see
Aristotle says there's nothing in the
soul that doesn't get there through the
senses so that's a kind of a limit well
once you see what those problems are you
can imagine a being that learns all at
once
also a being that learns all the time or
knows everything doesn't learn knows
everything knows everything in an
instant sees everything in an instant
you see we're on our way up through
angels toward God and that means city
implications of God are in the hierarchy
of things including us and in the
imperfection even of the highest things
that we see and that means that the
humanities raise the question of God and
so you need to be thinking about that
but then think about this how are you
going to know about God because if you
imagine a perfect being it would be
omnipotent that means it could do
anything and then on the other hand to
be omnipotent it would need to be
omniscient it wouldn't mean to know
everything and if it was the origin of
things it would be the Creator now I
will tell you that in Greek philosophy
they don't imagine a creator because
they stick with what they see and they
say that the planners are always there
and they always move in the patterns
they move and baby dogs give a grown-up
dogs give rise to baby dogs and acorns
produce oak trees and so the implication
is
that it's gone on forever but on the
other hand they did I asked the question
you know did all this start somewhere
and if so where and if there actually
was a creator then he would actually
have to be outside nature he wouldn't be
just that dense lump at the beginning of
things he'd have to be something outside
that thing to be the source of it and he
would need to be an eternal thing a
thing that didn't start in order to be
perfect I'm saying and so then you start
drawing a picture of God and that
picture is supported by the traditions
of learning that come to us especially
through Judaism and Christianity in
Christianity Jesus is the word that's
what God has to say just like we say use
words and only we use them and so
there's an invitation in the faith to
think and try to explain understanding
that we're unlikely to be able to
explain everything at once including
especially the thing of which we could
have no sensory evidence the creator of
everything and that's why in the
tradition the study of God theology has
always been part of the Canon of the
liberal arts and fits in the Canon
understanding that it's that the
faithful part of it the revealed part of
it but that part is a different kind of
knowing than the kind that we undertake
when we observe and think and record and
calculate and in the Natural Sciences
experiment and it doesn't mean that
they're not both valuable but they are
different and so to call yourself a holy
thoughtful people as far as a human
being could be person wholly thoughtful
person you'd have to do some thinking
about God and that's what we think here
at Hillsdale College and always have
thought now I should mention an
interesting feature of the college
because I said these four things all
act and react upon each other and they
form an integrity and here's the funny
thing
just as the articles of association say
the teaching of the Christian faith by
precept and example shall remain a
conspicuous aim at the college it also
says that we are grateful to God to God
mind you for the inestimable blessings
of civil and religious freedom that
means everybody's got a right to worship
as he pleases and that is why although
this has been a seriously Christian
college from its first day soon next
fall 175 years ago until today it's also
true that we've never caught required a
face statement to attend here and that's
for the same reason that we don't ask
anybody if we don't demand that anybody
except conclusions here you have to
think of 3 for yourself and you owe
everybody else the best arguments you
can make about them why because we've
all agreed about the grounds of our
cooperation which is a travel of ports
so that's why how you sort of arbitrate
between these elements of our mission
but in a minute I say that word
arbitrate I take it back because they
actually form an integrity an attempt to
understand how and to be excellent human
beings creatures of God given with a
knowing mind and the students all commit
to themselves to undertake to know those
things to learn those things to make
them their own
so Genesis comes up a tremendous amount
it's also in the majors several majors
have extensive time devoted to this one
book of the Bible and maybe Shakespeare
and Plato and Aristotle get that much
attention among things and the
humanities but I can't think of anything
else so it's important here and then the
book of Genesis which is the first book
in the Bible is
profound serious and mysterious and I'll
mention a few things about it that make
it so first of all the first line is uh
in the beginning God created the heavens
and the earth I think I quote that
accurately who's speaking
that's an interesting question isn't it
because it would need to be God he would
be the only one there but on the other
hand later all through Genesis God is
often quoted introduced by and then God
said so here the first thing is left a
little unclear where does it come from
and that interesting and you can see
right now already this is an account of
the origins of things which is as I have
argued in both the natural sciences and
in the humanities a natural question
presented to the human being when he
begins to learn and this begins with God
did it and we don't know who tells us
the first eleven chapters there are 50
chapters in Genesis and the first eleven
chapters are like each other and the
last 39 are like each other the first
eleven are mysterious and general you
know there's the creation there's the
garden there's expulsion from the Garden
there's Noah and the flood
there's the growth of humanity there's
the Tower of Babel and the deprivation
of language and it ends there and then
on chapter 12 right at the beginning
begins a particular story and it's about
particular named people who live in
particular places and who are given
particular responsibilities by God
chapter 12 of Genesis begins with God
said to Abraham and I'm paraphrasing now
paraphrasing now Justin loves by the way
the translation of Jews
by Robert altar and I commend it to you
it's very serious and lovely piece of
work
both and that altar him I don't know him
but he must be a deeply learned man if
you read the preface and introduction to
that book you'll see what I mean
and in rough language God says get
yourself up and go to another place
where you never men take your family
leave your place there's a farming time
you leave your land and I'll make you a
great people and then this language and
this will be a blessing to all of the
people on the face of the earth that
means in Genesis with chapter 12 it's
not just a story of the creation of
everything including us our ancestors
it's always also a story meant for the
benefit of all of us this will be a
blessing to all the peoples on the earth
it's about the rest of Genesis that 39
chapters are about the choosing of the
Jewish people which turns out to be a
very hard duty Abraham we've got to go
he's got a almost sacrifice his son you
know the Sun and other offspring are
exactly what's been promised to Abraham
there's a meaning in that story and it
takes pondering to figure out what it is
because of course it's confusing too
because you're not supposed to be
sacrificing your children this is not a
god like some of the pagan gods who
demands child sacrifice for propitiation
and then on it goes from there you know
soon enough you get Jacob born and he
gets renamed Israel and he has 12 sons
and these twelve sons become the heads
of the 12 tribes and one of them Joseph
is the favored and he gets sold into
slavery and all that's part of a great
drama that ends with thee because you
know a Genesis ends with the point that
Jacob Israel has died and gone back home
to
be buried and then they all returned and
they're all still living in Egypt and
Joseph the one who founded their
position in Egypt Joseph speculates that
we're gonna get to go back home one of
these days but that's going to be hard
and so we need Moses and of course Moses
is the great figure in the wonderful
book of Exodus and Genesis sets the
stage for him so I hope you enjoy that
I'll tell you about Justin Justin's one
of the best teachers I've ever met one
of the best teachers here and that's
saying something he has a great thing
about him and that is he's one of the
hardest graders in the college and one
of the most popular teachers in the
college and if you think about that for
a minute that would be a reason for us
to be proud of our college because
that's not uncommon here
he's a litter he knows medieval stuff he
went to Purdue got a PhD there he's a
tremendous teacher of writing he knows
how to do that they have a famous
Writing Center at Purdue and he was a
graduate of it he made a deal with us
that when we hired him he wanted to
teach middle English and Dostoyevsky and
Genesis and he didn't want to run a
Writing Center and so what we did we
snuck at him
we organized a way for him to organize
the Writing Center but not have to spend
a lot of time on it and it's great the
way he did it I guess I'd say the only
complaint that I have about Justin is
that I cannot get him to trim his beard
apart from that he's awesome and I envy
you the privilege of meeting him for the
first time thank you for watching
you
[Music]